all I have are negative thoughts what a
terrible way to start a video I'm
quoting the dumb corn the Joker yeah but
did you know we're gonna go on the
internet you sorry YouTube you want to
admit like positive energy and I want to
start off with this whole negative
mindset that you have all people in the
comment section have is negative
thoughts I'm Greg hi I'm John we're
gonna watch from our friends at screen
junkies the honest trailer for Joker
arguably the most successful film of
2019 most Oscar nominations for 2020 you
guys before we go into that we put up a
video it's titled Zombieland double tap
interview with filmmakers plus monster
truck ride it is exactly what is in the
title we got to go to this really
awesome event where we got to ride
around in a monster truck in the Monster
Jam scene and then we got to interview
the screenwriters as well it was a
really great event and we put a lot of
work into editing that video I know it's
not normally what we do but would really
love it if you guys could go check that
video out there's a link in the
description box and then the pin comment
but anyway let's watch the honest
trailer for Joker
[Music]
never seen that it's like a no one look
arise
there's dog get rid of your contempt for
being a viral video star want to be
comedian have we learned nothing
[Music]
or die in a refrigerator
[Music]
large frog in my hair
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no songs
across the board Social Services is part
of that and easy access to guns to
protect yourself oh so wait
it wasn't offensive rally cry or an NT s
DW
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was great I hope he says that
whoever's the presenter great job on the
writing there people yeah great job on
the voice for John Bailey Bay great job
to the editors let's talk about some
things they talked about in the talking
of the talking about the Joker's for
starters what the hell was that Todd
Phillips footage I have no idea what the
hell that was from like Road Trip maybe
like it looked like a really young Amy
smarts toes I have no idea oh but you
know we all got to start somewhere
and that's where Todd Phillips started
yeah but now we can't do comedy anymore
now he's a groundbreaking dramatic a
tour of a director I loved a lot of the
jokes that they had in here you know I
don't really talk about the jokes they
make you tend to talk about the points
they make but there was some really
great jokes in there that line about
using the bare minimum of Batman to
qualify this as a Batman movie of sorts
or the comic book movie because that
seems to be one of the most common
criticisms of the film is we don't need
that Batman stuff in there but they
managed to include that Batman stuff and
I still stand on the side of they could
have just cut it in half a little bit is
OK with me
but yeah I don't agree with the
statement no no Bruce Wayne at all but a
little bit of Bruce Wayne and I think
it's fine I'm on the opposite way of
more Bruce Wayne and more you think it
should have been Bruce Wayne biopic he
should be fighting Batman in the sequel
that's what everyone wants and Warner
Brothers has to deliver the fans need
what they need put that joke they made
about you better killed that man before
he turns 12 and overpowers him I never
thought about that that's a great honest
trailers point because granite Arthur
Fleck was a completely different human
being by the beginning of that movie but
he did get overpowered had his ass
kicked by a bunch of teenagers at the
beginning of the film young Batman can I
get us practice in on Arthur before he
goes the real world but also the joke
about the the damage of the Joker of
Jared Leto's Joker within the ten doing
the damage there's a lot of great
montage jokes in here all the different
kinds of laughing that he did I didn't
actually notice the amount of different
kinds of laughter and then this montage
really puts it on display here I'm
getting punched and even the joke about
the stairs I thought was great and of
course you know when you're doing a
superhero movie you got to talk about
those marvel body shots or superhero
body shots so I loved that I relied rim
not rip rib that should be DC Warner
Brothers as thing is emaciated heroes
set themselves apart and every movie
will be like oh do you believe how many
pounds he dropped he's like 80 pounds no
I like that they brought up the idea of
how there's like the messages the points
the movies trying to make or sometimes
just really right in your face so I do a
lot of close-ups they have the big bold
text on the newspapers and stuff it's
pretty writ large across the movie yeah
I mean ever since the Joker got all
these like Oscar nominations I've been
seeing a lot on social media of how
undeserved it is especially in the
writing department they're like posting
clips that are very expositional very on
the nose I don't fully agree with it I
mean there are times where yeah it
totally is but then at the same time
certain scenes I think in the context
and the flow of the movie it's warranted
I think it totally works how people are
taking that clip of the interview with
Joker and Murray this got nomination for
Best Writing at this point in the movie
I feel like they would be pretty
expository with their dialogue in that
moment it's kind of like when they took
that clip of Adam driver and marriage
story to make fun of him on social media
like this guy's getting an Oscar
nomination when you take scenes out of
context that can look bad sometimes I
don't think that scenes great even if I
just watch that one clip still at the
same time though honest show there's
made a great point yeah it is really
they really want their message to be
seen made clear which is ironic kind of
funny because there was a lot of
controversy leading up to this as they
pointed out in this honest trailer and
in
controversy so many people were making
up their minds on what this movie is
about what it might ignite before they
even saw it and there are people there
people I actually know that still
refused to see the movie because they
still think that that is what it is
about that's what it's gonna altom utley
inspire I don't know of any violence
that has occurred because of this movie
because the movie is not about pushing
that or trying to provoke you in that
arena the point is yeah very much the
opposite yeah I think I was funny yeah
when the movie finally dropped and then
the controversy is still there like it's
a movie that you can look at from
multiple angles especially the lead up
for this one made me very tired and
almost sick of the movie before I got
here I appreciate though they either
they brought that up because that was
one of my kind of few complaints about
the movie is that yeah they do really
hammer on a lot of their points make
everybody behave in service of him yeah
I thought the Martin Scorsese mumblecore
riff joke was pretty fun too just
because I wouldn't have thought of
mumblecore but there are a lot of those
elements too it's funny because Scorsese
says he refuses to watch the movie he
was in line to produce the movie at one
point I think the rumors about him
directing it were false but producing
was something that he was supposed to be
on board for says he refused to watch it
his homeboy Robert De Niro's in it have
you guys seen the Hollywood round table
with the directors the most recent one
there was Todd Phillips and Martin
Scorsese there where Scorsese clears up
once again some of his superhero
comments and then todd phillips even
goes out of his way to say like no this
is supposed to be like the anti
superhero movie i just feel kind of bad
for todd phillips not for everything
else everything else in his life seems
to be going pretty great but the fact
that this movie is in so many ways a
love letter to the Scorsese cinema that
he grew up on and that filmmaker just
has no interest or doesn't care to watch
it just kind of bums me out for the guy
because I feel like that if any director
he'd want to watch this movie it's gonna
be Martin Scorsese you're unable to kiss
the ring and you might get slapped with
it like it's such a unique position and
it is such a big significant movie for
last year that it is kind of a bummer
and surprising yeah he says he
apparently won't watch it because it is
one of the films that you could argue
disparaging you know disproves this
point a little bitter or at least
detracts from
point I think it's a little bit of a
missed opportunity but I am NOT a master
filmmaker maybe he's right
that footage of the Joaquin Phoenix
interviews he's remembered I'd wheel you
guys around but not everyone was really
aware of that at the time when what was
that I'm still here I'm still really out
with documentary film I'm still going no
one what it's funny how like the the
promo things they did the publicity
stunts they did for it were
significantly more popular than the
box-office return on that movie yeah
everyone's sick of it by the time the
movie had the idea that it was a
documentary they really kept that hidden
for a long time and so people thought
Joaquin Phoenix kind of just lost his
mind he seemed like the kind of guy who
could just lose his mind one day so it
seemed like believable and I love
walking Phoenix's interviews I feel like
he's been the absolute best of the
interviews in terms of promoting this
movie maybe because he has to promote
him more than any other movie he's ever
done before and shouts out to his Golden
Globe speech mainly because of this for
like the past year I have been
contemplating you know like cutting back
on eating meat become a more plant-based
potentially becoming a vegetarian two
sorts and I was like alright for maybe
in the new year I'll commit to that idea
of like not eating meat at least once a
week to my part as opposed to more than
it's like it's important to give your
money to charity and all that but at the
same time like there's something more it
could be doing right oh he gave a speech
for some reason it just clicked in me
right then and there you know what I'm
gonna commit to this so in the month of
January I've now gone 11 days without
eating any of there have been some days
I've eaten meat but 11 days with no meat
is a big milestone for me and the major
final nail in the coffin was walking
Phoenix's speech for some reason so that
goes to show you the power of celebrity
influences people that's why it's
important what they say I don't have
mentors in real life so I take them from
celebrities and some little snippets of
things they say because I want to be
just like them one day I wouldn't have
known what's vote for had it not have
been for the Golden Globes and the
Oscars that's that's my daily show
anyway there's a great honest trailer
thank you screen junkies for doing this
guys make sure to go check out that
video that I talked about the top of
this one leave in the description box
pin comment subscribe click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever
got a YouTube video what before I wrap
this up I'd like to end this with a
patron today shout out to a man named
Chris wham off Chris wham off is a guy
who really helps out his community
definitely an environmentalist I love
this human being every time I talk with
him and it's a pure positive to life but
I do have a serious question for you
Chris when you touch yourself do you
call that the WAM off or the that was
gonna be dirty I was gonna try and John
sure nothing tops the whammo no nothing
tops think atop that joke
alright I'm lammed off this afternoon
granted that is your last name yeah so
like your parents have that name and
yeah they way my siblings a lot of
people who emma i hope that when you do
wham off and you go wham off its 12/2
the images of your parents totally yeah
that's what most people think about in
that situation you know cuz they gave
you lyfe guys there's no shame in
whamming off do it it's good for your
body you know it promotes healthy
reproductive health Upson what it helps
to reduce breast cancer yeah